hey guys today I'm going to show you how
to download and install and apply
add-ons for Apple Safari web browser as
well as WebKit which is at the previous
video on its to go check that one first
thing you want to do is open Internet
browser that you want to use any one for
this and go to apple.com
I have a bookmark here but it's it's
just apple.com and I'm gonna tap
obviously there's a number of downloads
from Apple with their recent App Store
add-on what you will hear is Safari
version 3.2 if you can't that you can
actually search it up here and Safari
but you really don't have to just click
on the link or the word Safari on the
page so I guess and here it'll say why
you love Safari and everything and it'll
give you the links to download Safari
but at the bottom it says for richer
browsing experience and they want to
install plug-ins for Safari on windows I
click on that it's downloading already
and here are all begins there are six of
them I know it's not Firefox like but
there are six of them and I have all
these installed Adobe Reader Flash
Player QuickTime Player Java which is
appropriate for playing games or
chatting online or something real player
and the web media player now to see
which ones you already have installed
simply hit window and I think it's
helped and installed plugins and here
it'll bring up all the instructions you
have I have Java I have QuickTime flash
Windows Media Player and shockwave and
reader so all all of these are add-ons I
have the Silverlight plug-in so all
these add-ons that I already have in
Safari these also work in WebKit so I'm
going to exam Safari and open up the
WebKit build
obviously that it'll go through the
command prompt window again which is
what I showed you in my last video so
give it a second
and then it'll open up Safari its what
good and again to see which to see which
add-ons you install go to help and
installed plugins and it'll show you
which ones you have installed to install
them you already know go to apple.com
downloads and safari and plug-ins for
safari on windows so they are if you
want to get the plugin just hit the get
plug-in button say I want realplayer
I'll hit the button that says get
plug-in and it says click the download
for your operating system
it works for Vista and those older
versions XP Mac OS 10 and also older
version of older versions of the Mac OS
Linux UNIX and mobile devices so a
download link it will say if you want to
save it or open it hit open or give it
to your desktop and then open whichever
you like and that will install it and
sorry that'll plug it right in and
you'll be able to use those add-ons
whenever you like it's not quite the
same as a firefox reading experience but
I do recommend this for a richer
browsing experience sorry so if you
sorry I highly recommend those thanks
for watching if you guys have any video
requests or tutorial ideas for me send
me a message or leave a comment or
something and I will get around to it
I'll do my best so thanks for watching